hi so i am heather nolis and i am here
to talk about
speech the other other nlp where nlp is
natural
language process um and i work at
t-mobile um so a little bit
more about me uh i actually am a machine
learning engineer and i started at
t-mobile in 2017.
but before that i really wanted to get
my phd in neuroscience and that's how i
actually got into programming was
um i did a study and i had lots of
beautiful
microarray data and they were like pass
it off to the analytics team and i was
like no thank you
i'm a control freak i'm gonna learn and
go learn how to program this and do
clustering myself
um and so that's how i got into the the
field of data science at all
and i'm extremely active on twitter so
you can follow me there but if you want
like a real response
it's much easier to connect with me at
work because i tend to
take my work communications pretty
seriously so if you want a good response
time
my work email is is right there um and
then just a little bit about what a
machine learning engineer does
at t-mobile is my team consists of
analysts and
software engineers and architects and
data scientists and machine learning
engineers
and our goal is to build full stack
software and the role of the machine
learning engineer is really to work with
the data scientists who are actually
building the models and get those models
working well in the context of the
entire software ecosystem so making sure
that they're performant they are apis
um so that way our data scientists can
kind of really focus on the modeling and
so
uh this talk will be focused on a lot of
that extra stuff that goes into
making data science models run and work
at scale
so my team is called ai at t-mobile and
we really focus on
well we did focus on customer care
messaging so what this means is that if
you have a problem with your phone you
can pull it out and you can
uh text or go to twitter or go to
facebook or apple business chat and
write a message to t-mobile and have
them actually have a conversation with
you about
the issue that you're having
asynchronously via text which
i love i hate phone calls um and so
we're really focused
in that world where everything's text
messages it's back and forth and how can
we leverage
the context of the conversation to
really provide
insights to our our call center experts
sitting there trying to troubleshoot
your problem
and we call it ai under the covers so uh
we don't want to do anything that's
flashy and in your face or gets between
a customer and the solution that they
want so we're focused on building ai
that helps
experts in call centers solve problems
faster um
we're focused on helping the coaches for
those care experts
measure the impact of the strategic
initiatives that they have
and we're really focused on providing
self-cuss service for customers like
chat bots and things but only if the
customers
really want that option so we don't do
phone trees no persistent or no
disclosure chat bots
no creepy monitoring disguised as
personalization we're really focused on
making sure that our ai is ethical
disclosed and
tucked away and not not stealing the
show from the things that really matter
uh which are customer problems and so
our flagship product was called
expert assessed and how expert assist
works is it sits
um in the on the computer
where the experts are looking at
care conversations and you you've all
called into care and so in general when
you call on the phone you might have to
sit in a queue and wait
um until that someone can talk to you
the very same is true and text messaging
so if you text message in it might be
one to two minutes before an expert
actually has a second
to get to your problem so we were
thinking in the time between you sent us
your first message and the time between
the care expert gets to look at your
account
what cool things could we do that would
let that care expert solve your problem
quicker
so when you message in and you say
something like hey i'm traveling to
europe and i need my phone to work we
have about two minutes to munch data
and what we do is we we classify the
topic um and these are using models
built in r that are
tensorflow cares models that are
containerized in docker containers
and that spits out a conversation topic
we also look up relevant internal
wikipedia articles that would help you
solve the issue as the care expert so in
this situation
i didn't know how to unlock a phone good
news lots of information there about how
to unlock a phone
and then we also pull up relevant
account backs that tell that would help
the experts say okay well it's an iphone
x and i know this about iphone x's and
here's
exactly how we um unlock those and then
um the model moves into a real-time
situation where actually slides along
the conversation so if this conversation
pivoted and we began to talk about
how i really need to pay off my my huge
bill before i unlock my
phone um those things would update in
real time sub
sub one second is how quickly we want it
to update we want to be
extremely responsive and interactive to
the conversations that are going on
and so this is a story all about how
my boss looked at expert assist and said
uh cool make it work and voice now
so in this 20-minute segment just sit
right there and i'm gonna tell you how
uh actually the skills needed to deploy
and train models and voice are
completely separate from the skills
needed to deploy and train models and
text and the
the stunning journey of how i learned
that
and we had to prove that i could do it
in just 60 days or that our team could
produce this product and we only had 60
days to do it
so my first response when my boss said
take expert assist which works in text
message and make it work in voice
i want the scrappiest easiest just prove
to me you can do it i was like this will
be super super simple
all you got to do is send me the sound
i'm going to go out and get amazon aws
google microsoft some vendor
to do speech to text because that's
totally a solved problem
and our models will work very well
because they've already been optimized
and they're on kubernetes so the scale
will be fine
so even though voice has 10 times the
traffic messaging does i don't worry
about it
and our models will work just fine if i
retrain them on voice data i won't need
to restructure do anything really big as
far as the models are concerned it
should be very simple
um literally literally every piece of
this was incorrect
um so some other things i got wrong uh
just to throw them out there i thought
that sending telephone audio to a
computer would be easy
i thought that we could have any
speech-to-text product work and it would
it would make our models
it would be sufficient for our models to
perform well i thought our models would
be able to handle a 10-time scale
increase with a 10 times container
increase
um we would have that linear matching
without a lot of refactoring
and i thought our models would perform
the same so i thought if you
if you gave us the topic if you gave us
a voice conversation about payment
arrangements our topic model would
classify it just
as well as if it was a text conversation
um
but that was all wrong so i'm going to
walk through my major assumptions one by
one and tell you exactly how wrong i was
uh so the first thing i said was just
send me the sound because you know
that's
super easy um and so in my dream it
would go something like this the
customer would say
thou any bogo iphone deals for me thanks
and you know the network would do its
thing audio would be converted to text
our servers would pump it out and boom
it would just appear
on the agent's screen and they would be
like yes that sounds great
it doesn't work like that so the first
issue we came across is
we couldn't get a copy of the voice
stream telephone
architectures are really old and
interesting they are not like computers
talk to each other at all
and so we only had two copies of the
voice stream
one of those was from the customer to
the care expert
and the other one was for coaches to
listen in and help out if necessary
so that leaves zero zero zero voice data
for our models to actually run on um
to get our models to run on voice data
we had to install install hardware at
our t-mobile
on-premise data centers that can create
a copy of the audio stream and send it
out this is a
millions of dollars like a multi-million
dollar investment
um installing hardware can can take
months and months and months we only had
60 days
so that's the first issue so if we can
get buy-in from stakeholders we can get
millions of dollars then maybe we can
get a copy of the audio but
how can we think of the data to our
models our models live in the cloud and
the telephone data lives in on-premise
data centers sending data
back and forth takes time so when you're
texting with somebody if you have to
pause for
30 seconds and go and get a drink of
water that's totally okay
if you pause for 30 seconds in a phone
call it feels like you're being ignored
if that's the opposite of what we want
to do with the whole ai under the covers
thing we want we want our artificial
intelligence to be unobtrusive
so if our models are ignoring you and
our reps are ignoring you because the
models are still processing what
happened 30 seconds ago that's not a
good experience you need to be
incredibly quick
and then there's the issue that
telephones weren't made to talk to
computers
telephones use uh sip and rtp streams to
actually create telephone calls so sip
will like
do the job of creating the call and rtp
basically sends the audio data back and
forth there's one stream from the caller
to the recipient
and then from the recipient to the
caller but computers don't talk like
that computers talk using
text streams and apis and websockets so
basically it seemed like this was an
impossible endeavor
until we had a realization which you
probably have had because we are all on
a video sharing service um
and that's lots and lots of people have
already solved the problem of how to get
telephones to talk to computers
zoom does it skype does it webex does it
anytime that you can call into a video
conference call
they've already solved this problem so
what we did is we leveraged these
connectors from amazon chime which is
amazon's video conferencing product
and then uh amazon kinesis streams to
actually convert the sip
rtp streams which is like old school
telephony data
to a format that our computers can
understand which is websocket audio
streams
so great we're able to buy ourselves out
of this problem
also and so when i said send me the
sound
i showed you my beautiful flow chart
that was pretty linear of how i imagined
it going and it just doesn't look like
that actually
um how it works is somebody calls in
and that call data goes to the data
warehouse
in t-mobile's data warehouse it then
copies that stream
it sends one stream to the desktop where
the care agent is working so they can
listen to the call
then it sends one stream to our public
cloud
and in the public cloud that stream is
then sent to our private
it's converted into things that
websockets and things that computers can
understand
and it's sent to our private kubernetes
cluster which then
has to go back out to the public cloud
and say turn on the transcriber
and the transcriber then has to send it
back into our private cloud to our
models which can then eventually deliver
be delivered to the agent desktop this
is not how it works in text and text
it's very straightforward
um you you say a message you get a
result in this there's so much cycling
back and forth and each of those little
jumps adds a few seconds
so we're looking at a situation where
it's even more important that we're
really fast because in voice you have to
be on the ball and you can't have these
awkward pauses
but the steps between uh getting our
models results
and the the customer saying something
there are so many steps between it that
it's causing a lot of
a lot of lag that we didn't expect and
so that's the first issue
the second thing i was wrong about is
what i said i'll use a vendor to
translate the audio just fine
um i had always been under the
impression that since auto captioning
works you know mediocrity that that
speech text wasn't really a solved
problem
it's not most um transcription
models that you see in the marketplace
are built on a
wide band audio so that's six kilohertz
sampling rate
16 kilohertz sampling rate audio and um
that allows for a lot of richness and a
lot of information
that telephone audio doesn't because
telephone audio is limited to an eight
kilohertz sampling rate
this was a great decision for telephones
because ninety percent of the sounds
that actually make up language
are encompassed in that eight kilohertz
band the unfortunate thing
for models is that some very important
uh
sounds aren't actually there so like
when you're on the phone you can't
actually hear i believe it's f and s
sounds because they aren't encompassed
in that band your brain is actually
filling in those gaps for you
which is great because brains are great
at that but models are horrible at
filling in the gaps where we don't give
them data so
our out-of-the-box word error rates from
almost every major
speech transcription provider was almost
40 and so word error rate is how you
measure accuracy
of uh speech recognition or speech to
text and it's basically saying um how
many words did you get wrong
um and there's all sorts of ways to say
if it shifts a little bit how do you
change that calculation it can get very
very interesting and competitive and
nasty
but but by all metrics the
out-of-the-box word error rates for
these models were about 40
which means that our models like our
classification models are
only getting 60 of the information that
they would have otherwise because 40
is basically lost to garbage um and then
we also thought that these models would
serve all of our customers equally
however when we looked at these vendor
provided models from
again literally every big speech text
vendor they they all perform
worse on women and worse on accented
english
this is unacceptable because throughout
america even we have so many different
accents and t-mobile in particular we
have a huge base in georgia
we have a call center in nashville and
these are areas of the united states
with very distinct accents
and if we can't even get our call center
representatives
transcriptions good how will we ever get
the breadth of our customers good
and then we also thought that speed
wouldn't be an issue but we were having
up to five seconds of lag between when a
customer said something when we could
see the transcription
that's quite far behind in a voice
conversation so out of the box models
for telephone audio they suck it's not a
solved problem i was super wrong
i also thought that load would not be an
issue
and so what i mean by that is you know
we're going from having uh
ten percent of the volume that exists in
messaging like ten percent of the
overall care volume to having
a hundred percent of the care volume
which is ninety percent voice
um so the first issue is i thought that
that would scale linearly so i thought
the more confident like for each
conversation we need
each instance of our model could serve a
certain number of conversations and it
wouldn't matter if they were in text or
invoice
this isn't true because voice
conversations are extremely long you are
more likely to meander
to talk about absolute nonsense and
text-based conversations are very very
very business
so it turns out that when this is in
production the number of instances that
we need for 10 times the traffic was
actually
30 times the compute which is it's
very expensive and then there's lots of
moments when you're on the phone where
nobody's saying anything everyone's
called into a call center and had
somebody say let me pull up the details
on your account for you and set there
for a good two minutes and 30 seconds in
complete silence
we were paying people to transcribe
silence so
the load as far as actual conversations
increased but so did the amount of work
that our
models were having to do which was
unanticipated and it's extremely
expensive so we had a few strategies for
how to cut the cost so that way we can
still be viable
uh one very easy build a model to
determine silence and don't transcribe
silence um another strategy to lower the
model cost is that our
our classification models and our intent
models there are these big beautiful
neural network of neural networks like
extremely deep learning uh
our models that are containerized and so
they are a little bit resource intensive
because they
they are they are deep learning models
and so we created a low resource
importance model that after an utterance
is said
we determine whether or not we think
that that is information dense enough to
send to our classification model
the goal here being to filter out some
of the small talk that happens in voice
that doesn't happen in text
to try and increase our overall model
accuracy then we also toyed with
running these models as java services
which we
just got working literally yesterday and
there's a blog in progress and i'm
really excited to talk about that when i
finally can
um but the final assumption i mean this
is the most ridiculous one was that our
models will work just fine
um they don't they they are horrible uh
there are tons of things in casual
speech that casual text does not have
so you have increased filler words you
have back channeling
which is like when you're talking and
somebody said yeah uh-huh
so you have to deal with that you have
to deal with small talk as a concept
which really doesn't happen in business
text
you have to deal with two different
signal environments so we can control
what a call centers could sounds like
but i cannot control where a customer is
calling us from
the first transcription that i had to do
was a 20-minute call that took
multiple days for me to transcribe
because she had dogs barking in the
background
if my human brain can't transcribe text
how could i expect a model to do it and
then even with perfectly human
transcribed audio our overall model
accuracy for our intent
dropped almost 20 percent
so even if that even if it was if the
transcriptions were perfect we would be
losing 20
of our accuracy just because speech is
that much different than text
and these errors compound when you think
about all the transcription errors i was
mentioning so
our the the transcription models we were
spending a ton of money on were only
60 accurate and guarantee a 20
decrease in our accuracy so now we're
left with like some hot garbage to serve
up
um so i was wrong about literally
everything that i thought would make
this product easy uh so what's next
and what's next is we keep building um
we are working with
open source platforms and building our
own in-house models for speech-to-text
which is what i wanted to do from the
very beginning
but by taking 60 days and stitching
together all of these different
technologies and tying them to our text
stuff to build a prototype we were able
to secure enough funding
to start up a team that is actually
going to dig in and build these in-house
voice models of my dreams so we will
have equitable
voice models built on audio that serve
all of our customers equally and are in
our data centers
so that way they will be extremely fast
um and we're going to also work on
serving our models created in r as java
spring boot services
and then just refining the product
vision for the voice space because
in messaging our product was really
focused on context switching we had you
know a messaging agent might have six or
seven different windows open and they're
popping back and forth between all these
conversations but in voice
you're focused on one person's issues so
our problem space becomes different
where we make our bread and butter in
the voice spaces by eliminating all that
dead air
and so even though the results were
horrible
and all of my assumptions were
ridiculous we were able to prove that it
worked enough to get
millions and millions of dollars in
funding to do what i what i really want
to do and it's create beautiful models
in-house
and so in short what one does not simply
lift and shift to text and i'll be a
product to streaming voice and if you
are looking to do that
i hope that i've illuminated some of the
the stumbling blocks that will very very
obviously be in your way because it's
not as straightforward as it
as it seems but even with all of that
degradation we were able to prove real
value
and so the flip side of this is maybe
sometimes it's really okay to buy a bad
vendor product for a little while
if it gets you funding to build your own
in the end um and with that i would like
to say
thank you um everything that i've
learned in this entire project is really
from a machine learning engineer on my
team called phoebe parsons who has a
background in speech
so she was the person all around telling
me no heather don't go into the weeds
don't go in the weeds pulling me back
but still
there were so many little assumptions
that are made you think that this is
very simple
a simple simple technological problem
that doesn't involve a lot of modeling i
thought we had already built the models
and it turns out i was wrong we haven't
already built the models we have way
way way way more models to build now
with that thank you
um and if you want to talk to me i'm
extremely active on twitter but if you
want like fast business responses my
my work email is definitely the one to
take thanks